good morning that's the most response
I've ever had from a Norwegian audience
thank you hey if you're sort of towards
the middle in this room can you bunch
you in a little bit because a heap of
people sort of wandering up the stairs
like just give him a bit of space that
would be awesome and what are you doing
that I'm going to start my my intro on
what we're gonna do today which is hack
to the future everyone in the right
place okay good all right two for two
awesome okay so I'm talking about a
bunch of stuff related to various
hacking things and I'm talking about
some stuff that we've seen before and
some cool stuff that we've got that we
can do not just in the future but now
but it's kind of futuristic it's kind of
cool a lot of people don't know about a
lot of this stuff now just for context I
built a little project a few years ago
called have an impound has anyone used
however been playing before okay has
anyone not used to make it easy so I
don't have to explain what it is because
everyone seems to know what it is who's
been in say the drop box data breach
LinkedIn data breach actually Madison
dad no don't worry there's usually
someone always AG I don't know how that
works
so ever been poned is obviously a data
breach notification service on your way
out there's a heap of stickers here as
well so if you want to have a beam pain
sticker grab one of those it's got as of
yesterday when I grabbed at seven point
eight six billion records worth of data
in it and I originally created this
service back in 2013 and I thought oh
this will be a bit of fun like some of
my mates or years it they'll find
themselves in some data breaches it will
allow me to write some code because like
most of you I just want to sit there and
build stuff and when I started creating
it there were people who were a bit
skeptical they thought okay well maybe
this is me just harvesting spam and
ekkada started from this really innocent
simple time where I just wanted to build
software and it just kept getting bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger
and I think the point at which I went
well this is actually gotten really big
now you
when I ended up here so I went to
Congress about a year and a half ago
which was really really strange to me
because when they asked me to go and
this is obviously Congress in the u.s.
they call me up now you know can you
come and testify it's like you know I'm
Australian day like do you really want
you know convict heritage everything and
it was it was really big for me too
because I literally had to get dressed
up so every piece of clothing you see me
wearing I didn't have I had to go and
buy clothes like this is dressed up I
live on a freaking beach like I don't
really have to worry about these things
and I didn't want to sort of be too
serious about it either so I I tweet it
out and I said does anyone have some
cool socks you can send me and so forth
sent me some socks which in this photo
and the socks look like this so let's
say for those about the code we salute
you and and it and to me like this was
just really weird it's like I'm in
Congress wearing these socks talking to
lawmakers about like billions and
billions of records of illegally
obtained data that I've got and and then
it got even weirder because people
started taking photos of my socks and
putting them on shutterstock and you can
literally buy for 199 dollars a photo of
my socks I'm willing to do it for half
of that for anyone that wants to come
and take a photo after the after the
talk but I guess that the point is is
that this began as something very simple
the way many of you have probably sat
there and built hobby projects before
and it got big and it got very very
strange in many ways and I'm sure
there's many other talks that will come
later on about how weird things got so
getting back to the security side of
things in the data breach side of things
one of the things that I think a lot of
people don't understand is that a huge
number of the data breaches that go into
things like ever been poned are actually
really really simple in nature and they
happen to organizations of all different
sizes as well and I'll give you a really
good example of a very strange one
recently that hit one of the Australian
banks so this is one of our big four
banks tens of billions of dollars worth
of Revenue year and they had to come out
and make a disclosure statement only
earlier this year
and it related to the decommissioning of
a data center so they are shutting down
the data center moving to a new one and
they had to send all the records from
the old data center for secure
destruction so they get all the records
from the one data soon and they put them
on a truck now I've got some file
footage of the Commonwealth Bank truck
here and this is all the data so anyway
they get all the data I don't know if
they're like tapes or discs or what they
have but they put them all on the truck
and they drive the truck to the
destruction facility which is like one
of those big shredders you put the hard
disks and things in anyway it turns out
they might have put a bit too much data
on the truck
and at some point in time data is
actually falling off the truck this is a
true story
maybe the file footage bit I stretch the
imagination a little bit but it's
literally a true story
KPMG audited them and they said they
sent forensic investigators to retrace
the route of the truck to determine they
could locate the drives but were unable
to find any trace of them so this is
like data literally falling off the back
of a truck you know like we talked about
sophisticated nation-state threat actors
and all this sort of stuff and these
guys like yeah we put too much on the
truck something fell off so there's a
really weird sort of whole range of ways
that our data gets expose they're about
12 million records apparently which is
on him now one of the problems that I
have is every time someone sends me data
for have I been poned I have to try and
verify it it would be easy for me to
take it and just go yeah I'll just
upload it job done I can go back to the
beach and not worry but the problem is
is that if I do that it's gonna leave
the organisation who owns the data in a
very uncomfortable position they're
gonna be like what the hell like we
didn't know about this I don't know what
that might mean for my legal status as
well so I don't really want that to
happen so I always contact organisations
if it's not a publicly known incident so
if it's not in the press if they've not
made disclosure statements and one of
these recent incidents had to do with
this site so this is adult fan fiction
and I think that the banner ads sort of
best sums up the nature of the site
and it's basically like let's imagine
you have two vampires who are in love
and you want to write a story about it
and it gets a little bit hot and steamy
that's what the site is for it's
literally a dot fan fiction but like
werewolves and vampires and stuff yeah
okay whatever it's I don't mind but if
you've had a data breach I'd kind of
like to let you know about it
so someone sends me their data and I get
in touch with them and and this is one
of my sort of typical disclosure
messages and I sort of say to them look
you know here's Who I am someone sent me
some data and I always like to give them
a little bit of a proof so I don't just
seem like some Rando crazy stranger so I
gave them the three bullet points here
so here's some usernames and here's some
password hashes now any reasonable
person could take that from this
external identity which is me and they
could look at their database and go look
at that we've got three years of names
that have these hashes we probably
should talk to the guy that to me makes
sense but I didn't hear anything back
and this was the 19th of July this was
last year so 19th of July sent them all
this information like I said here this
should be sufficient for you to verify
the legitimacy the incident now they
didn't get back to me weeks later so
when in - have I been pwned 186 thousand
records that include names dates of
birth email addresses and passwords
stored in both md5 and plain text the
beauty of this method is if you want to
upgrade your hashing algorithm later on
it's very easy just take the plaintext
and I still don't know why they did that
of course 79% of them already and have I
been pwned as well so the other thing
that shows you is very frequently when I
load data breaches a huge number of the
people in there have already been in at
least one other data breach it's very
rare to see less than 50% and if you
have a look at the heavier being pound
account every single time I load data I
put the percentage in there because I
find it fascinating to see how many
people are getting rebound so it goes
and have a been poned
I've got about 2.8 million subscribers
now so when I load data if any of those
subscribers are in the data breach they
get an email which says hey you've just
been in this day
rich and inevitably some of them are
also adult fanfiction members so they
post it on the forum someone says hey
I've got an email from have I been poned
and the last line there says is this
true and why hasn't it been addressed is
the site still vulnerable now you'll see
why it hasn't been addressed in a moment
and the answer to the second question is
almost certainly yes
now when you see this when someone says
hey I use this site I just got a
notification from an independent service
saying that they know that I use this
site and my daughter is out there
there's a pretty good chance that they
use this site and it's harder as our bet
when two people say it it's a really
really good chance so you got multiple
people now chiming in saying hey I've
just got notified from her phone now
this is never the way I want this to
happen I don't want them to hear from me
first I want them to hear from adult fan
fiction because they're the organization
that lost the data actually it's a wrong
turn to use they still have it there's
just more backups globally now and what
they were before so eventually the forum
administrator chimes and this is demon
goddess she's a head evil tech wench
told you my life gets weird now doesn't
it and she says now it's not true one
would think that instead of scaring
users these companies incidentally this
company's like just me would contact the
site itself well I sent you an email and
I said that email to two different
addresses both publicly published as
contact connections contacted email
addresses for the company - so she
wasn't very happy about this and she
sent me an email said none of the -
exists in my database
sorry flight responsibly working
collation sales and my day job demon
goddess 61 and Hoss I had this small
diamond goddess does during the day that
maybe she's a lawyer in a suit I was
just and Aslan a no it doesn't matter
so she emails me again separate email
and said now verify this doesn't it's my
dad wait so expect you to remove the
site from your - which website now
please no like this is a legitimate
breach this definitely happened
and that the frustrating thing is that
not only had I independently verified
that it was from their site but their
members are popping up going this other
site have I been poned now has my data
so obviously it's legit and it's just a
painful painful exercise trying to
convince them so the discussion
continues and someone else chimes in
Bronx when she's a mighty dragon wench
and she says there's no gain in hacking
us we're not an e-commerce site you know
this I always find fascinating where
there's this view that because you don't
hold credit card data no one wants to
hack you
you know why people want to hack you
you're on the internet that's it job
done stand up something on the internet
tomorrow with the new domain name and
nothing on there at all and see how long
it takes to get scanned by automated
tools trying to find vulnerabilities if
you're looking to terrify people into
buying security software maybe I should
sell security software it could be an
upside anyway I don't this is an
extremely effective gambit so you say
sort of a defensive pattern so even
after I've emailed them and there's a
link to have I been partners and about
paid and it literally says and I went to
Congress and everything just to try and
give me like an air of legitimacy and
they jump to this incidentally like I'm
not just singling these guys out like
there this is a very standard response
from any organizations who just don't
want to accept that they've been
breached
so she goes on sell private workshops
this is true during those you'll be
offered the opportunity to purchase
security packages to prevent data breach
from impacting you was anyone at my
workshop this week and got offered
security packet now don't say yes just
to mess with me either
yes no no you didn't and I just want
like I don't understand how they get to
this point and all the time it's like
you've got a hundred and eighty six
thousand of your customers with their
plaintext passwords out there and
because of what people do they're the
same passwords they use on their bank in
their social media and their email do
something about this perhaps we don't
have high-priced lawyers who'll take him
to court perhaps he thinks the members
weren't reporting for publishing the
data their permission that's what I
intend to do that was August nothing
still alive and still free
so a lot of this is sort of posturing as
well as it's almost like those stages of
grief right and in fact I wrote a blog
post several years ago the five stages
of data brief grief and they go through
this like denial phase and anger phase
and it always always always ends up at
the same point which is acceptance which
is eventually they have to acknowledge
it which is why this thread has since
been deleted which is why I made sure
archive.org had it before it got deleted
so you can always go and see it again
there so another good example of this
this is Louis Louis's Dublin rail system
light rail system and back in January
this year the website looked like this
first of January few days later it
looked like this not so good and this
this person here says you're hacked some
time ago I wrote you have serious
security issues you didn't reply the
next time someone talks to you press the
reply button and this is also very often
the problem because we contact people
and we say hey look you've got a serious
security vulnerability you need to fix
it now there are then sort of a couple
of different pars you can go down after
identifying this trying to contact and
not getting any success one of those
pars is you just go oh well and you move
on the other path is you just delete the
website and you replace was something
completely different
not my chosen strategy because I like
freedom but for this guy it was like
okay look I'm just gonna literally blitz
your site so he then says I need some
Bitcoin
so maybe motives not so altruistic and
very shortly after Louis tweets third
again they say website was compromised
this may take the day to resolve third
of January a week later so it looked
like this a week after that so it looked
like this it wasn't really getting
resolved so this really seriously
knocked them offline for many weeks most
of January they're offline and you have
to wonder if they had it just replied to
the person in the first place if it
would have ended up this way or not and
that this sort of brings me
to the point of these examples which is
we need better mechanisms for disclosure
we need websites to provide people with
better channels than to get in touch and
we do have a good solution for this and
it's this has anyone seen security that
takes T before alright so this is like
one two percent of the audience and this
is the cheapest easiest fastest thing
you can do in the world so what you do
is you literally create a text file
security dot txt and you put it in the
dot well-known folder of your website
and I can show you what it looks like
for example and have I been poned so
that is my security look txt and this is
a spec which says hey look if someone
finds a security issue of vulnerability
or if they find data or they have
anything else security related here's
who to contact
you can put an email address and put a
social media account you can put your
public key and it is a text file it's
the simplest simplest thing in the world
so this spec was created by a guy called
a head overflow and he's been getting a
lot of traction on this there's a lot of
sites that are now starting to add
security dot txt unfortunately none of
the sites I've ever seen have a data
breach have had it but we have sites
such as Google so this is there as
Google's gone all in Google's got a huge
number of their different TLDs all
running security like txt they've got
acknowledgments policy hiring if you're
the sort of person who looks for a
security dot txt file you might be the
sort of person who wants a job with them
Dropbox has got one of course they had a
big data breach back in 2016 so now
they're very very conscious about being
contactable BBC has a massive one as
well massive comments in there and this
is fine like this is the place to put
that and if you want to get a sense of
who's using it have a look at this site
so crawler dot ninja is Scott Helms site
and he crawls through the Alexa top 1
million every single night and he
indexes different security things about
them and one of the things he indexes is
who has a security dot txt so it's
interesting to go there and see all the
different companies that have it and I'd
love all of you to go back to your
organization's and say do we have a
security duct txt and if not get
in place the biggest barrier to this is
convincing lawyers and why would have
heard before I was doing some training
in a bank recently and I saw someone
afterwards after I'd recommended this I
said you know how's your security that
texty going it's like are the lawyers
don't like it they think people are
gonna try and hack us like mate I hate
to break it to you this is what's
happening every day all right so get one
of those in place now one of the big
problems we've seen with hacking
recently is related to mage card and
mage cut is a collective of people who
seems we've been very good at getting
our credit card data so credit card data
entered into websites and we've seen
some really big headlines about big
organizations getting hit by mage code
so British Airways was one of them
380,000 sets of payment details and when
we say payment details this is not just
the full account number of the card the
expiry date the name on the card
it's the CVV as well it's everything and
these headlines come out and people have
been losing their minds because I've
said well you're not meant to store the
CVV post processing how on earth does
this happen
Ticketmaster was another one massive one
huge amount of data stolen Ticketmaster
another big global brand och so as well
so oXXO does a lot of sort of kitchen
goods big big brand in the US and all of
these websites have had mage cart
stealing credit card data from them and
people sort of been going well how does
this work so I've done up a demo to show
you how this works in a really really
easy defense now I want to show you what
was in the Ox a source code and then
we'll look at the mechanics of how it
actually works so I went to our
archive.org and pulled back the history
of the Ox a page and there was this
script in there now that script is not
normally meant to be on the oxford
website and it looks benign j/s cloud j
is - cloud comm normally they wouldn't
call it like mage cart keystroke logger
or something you know it's always like
some really benign name and in that file
was this now as you can clearly see from
this code it takes all of the fields
entered into the page and sends them
somewhere else I'm going to give you a
simple example
there's literally what it does it looks
for certain fields in the code so things
like email address and country and
region and it waits to see when that
field changes and when that field
changes it sends that data
asynchronously off to one of the major
card domains now all you have to do is
get a piece of script on the page so if
you can get a piece of script on British
Airways or on oxer on Ticketmaster you
can start to scrape off anything that's
entered in there so the way mage code is
working they're not stealing data from
storage they're stealing it literally
from the browser as people enter it so
let's have a look at how this works I
did up a little demo this just runs
locally on my machine so it's not live
and if I jump into the source code of
this page right there on the bottom
we've got this piece of code this goes
off to evil cyber hacker comm again
normally they're a little bit more
subtle than the names they use but
perfect example mage cutlet jeaious so
what happens here is that if we go down
to the credit card processing and I open
my dev tools I go to network every time
I change fields there's going to be an
async request and this async request
sends off the data in the field and if
we have a look at something like this we
can see the request URL and it says hey
there is a token here this token is a
constant across every one of those three
requests so that they can tie the
attributes together this is the host
name it's come from so you could
literally take this script and dump it
on every single website you can get your
hands on and then the host is identified
in this request here's the name of the
field and then here's the value so
here's a credit card number the response
just as I got your payment details you
wouldn't normally do that it wouldn't
come back with anything for demo
purposes only so this is a problem if
you can get the script on the site you
get to scrape everything off as it's
entered people are getting script on
sites because there's a lot of sites
running things like outdated CMS's
they've got vulnerabilities that haven't
been patched they've got admins with
weak credentials admins who get fished
but there's loads of different ways of
getting access to the CMS so that you
can drop on a line of script there are
good defenses for this
easy defenses so let's do this I'm gonna
go over to this example here it's the
same page it's just got one tiny little
difference and the difference is this if
I reload this page I've got a Content
security policy on this page and a
Content security policy is literally
just what you see here it's a response
header and this response set header says
hey you're only allowed to load content
from this site I can load scripts from
this site I can load fonts from this
site I can have blocks of script there
unsafe inline scripts only from this
site and if anyone by any means manages
to get a script tag on this site that
tries to pull in a scripts from
somewhere else it'll get blocked it
won't work we can see that it doesn't
work because if I go to the console is a
big error it says hey refused to load
the script so this is exactly the same
HTML source code as a previous page the
only difference is that header and this
is so simple it's so simple and the
thing is is the attack vectors that
allow you to get a script on the page
such as a compromised CMS generally
don't allow you to modify the response
headers so you can't modify the content
security policy as an attacker so this
is awesome and this is really that the
first step in so far as we've blocked it
that's great
however if this is my site I kind of
want to know that someone is doing this
as well I don't just want to blocked I
want to be told that it's blocked and
this brings us to the next example here
so identical page again but this time if
I have a look at the network tab and I
reload the page and we'll go and we'll
have a look at our CSP we see the same
CSP as before but now I've got this
report URI directive as well and the
cool thing about the report your eye
directive is you can say if the content
security policy fires send a report to
whatever URI I like so that I get
notified that it's been violated like
something weird is going on with my page
and this is sending it off to Troy hunt
don't report URI calm and report your I
calm as a project Scott helm and I ran
together and we receive
reports from organizations doing exactly
the sort of thing we receive about 700
million reports a day at the moment
because that's how often content
security policies and other mechanisms
that can report get fired now because
it's sending a report I can also go down
in my network tab and I can have a look
at what that report is so somewhere in
here there'll be a link to that where is
it here's mage cart getting blocked so
that's cool that one's blocked here is
the report URI are defined it's a post
request which means it has a body and I
can go down and have a look at this body
which is all in JSON and it says hey we
blocked this URI we refuse to load evil
saw hacker.com
slash mage cut that Jas this is the
document URI that it was on which is
what you see in the address bar it
violated the script source element which
effectively means it tried to insert a
script tag now imagine you got that
information about your website that is
everything you need to figure out what's
actually going on with your site and
this is built into the browser it's free
it's supported by every browser today
and has been for some years so content
security policies are really really cool
and they just completely nail this mage
cut problem that we've got at the moment
so I was sort of fun and fascinating to
see that we're still having problems
with mage cart and it's like you know
there's like a totally free defense out
there right now the British Airways one
was a little bit interesting because
what happened with them was it wasn't
someone getting script on their page it
was someone getting script on this and
this is inventor it's a chat bot so
British Airways themselves went directly
compromised but because their supply
chain led through to inventor and
inventor got compromised then that
cascaded back down so that the fun thing
for you to think about ok maybe not so
much fun the thing to think about is how
many dependencies do you have sort of
upstream of your website how many
different things you pull in from
different places what if one of those is
compromised and again you can fix it
with CSP CSP will cascade all the way
down to the likes of inventor as well
all right so that's sales paid now sales
pays are awesome they are here today and
they're getting really really rapid
adoption as well so go and check those
out something else that's getting rapid
adoption is IOT and connected things
this is a connected car and I always
found it fascinating you know why would
you bother to connect a car and then I
did a workshop a few years ago here in I
was low and in this workshop we had this
exercise where we take our mobile
devices and we proxy the mobile device
through the PC very easy to do if you've
got a Mac you can run Charles proxy if
you've got a PC you can run fiddler
route your phone through the PC and you
can see all of the traffic from your
mobile apps now that the interesting
thing about mobile apps is that they
hide a lot of really bad design
decisions so in your browser let's say
you go to a website and there's a you
see a link or a URL and something like
foot so users foot / - and you go I
wonder what would happen if I change it
to 4/3 and you guys another user it's
very easy to discover this stuff behind
a mobile app you don't have that easy
visibility to things like URLs - things
like the scheme being used it's hard to
see if it's HTTP or HTTPS so a lot of
stuff doesn't get tested as well but
it's easy for you to discover it just by
routing your device so anyway we're
doing this workshop and I've routed my
phone through the PC and everyone's
doing this by themselves as well and one
of the guys in my workshop has one of
these cars and this car has a mobile app
to control features of it looks like
this and I was actually quite fascinated
by this I said why would you want a
mobile app to control your car and the
guy said well that the reason why is
annoy it gets so cold we have to be able
to turn the heater on in the car before
we get into the car is this true
okay right so so I'm learning here
something you might be interested in
learning in Australia we have a
different problem in Australia get into
your car and summer and this happens and
and this is a real photo so maybe we
need one to cool the car down beforehand
anyway so
he's got this mobile app and it's
controlling features of his car doesn't
just control the climate control it can
also pull back the trip history and it
can pull back the battery status and the
guy is interested he's like well there
must be a way for my phone to know which
car to talk to so maybe there's like a
bearer token or something like that
there's a secret somewhere in my mobile
app that's getting passed to the API so
the API then toxic wrecked car so he
proxies his device he's looking for the
secret and he discovers that the secret
API key is printed in the windscreen of
every car it's literally the VIN number
and we did what you did we laughed
briefly very briefly and what what was
even worse is it's it's not just a
problem knowing the VIN number it's a
problem because VIN numbers are
innumerable as well so I was walking
around Oslo after just taking photos and
s and Leafs go and that's my car that's
my car and the problem is you can take
those last numbers and just keep
incrementing numbers and finding other
cars and as you find each K
hypothetically you can start to turn on
the climate control and control features
of the car so I said ah this is this is
bad I got it gotta let Nessa know about
this so I tweeted and I said does anyone
have a security contacted Nissen so it's
funny when I tweet that everyone's like
oh [__] this isn't gonna be good and and
inevitably someone gets in touch pretty
quickly so we we have a bit of email or
we get on the phone I talk about it I go
look this is really bad you guys have
got to like take this offline fix it
then get it back online and they're like
yeah and I will talk about it have a
have a a meeting and then nothing's
happening and I'm emailing these guys
back after a week two weeks three weeks
nothing's happening and then eventually
I discover that other people have
learned about the same vulnerability and
the way I discovered it was was this
there's a forum about Nissan Leafs and
there are people on the forum saying
their app is really crap so here's what
you do you want to be in bed all warm
and toasty you want to turn the heater
on in your car what you do go to this
URL change the VIN number
your own put it as a bookmark on your
phone to make the car hot and then
there's another bookmark to make the car
cold and all of you are getting really
upset now because it's changing state
with get request but that's not the
point the problem is is that they had
literally discovered like the secret
source to control other people's cars
and they hadn't quite realized it so I I
went back to this and said look I'm
going to write about it because you know
other people just go it here's the link
and they said please don't do that so I
wrote about it and I I needed to figure
out like what's what's the right way to
do this
to to get traction on the issue so it
needs media attention because media
attention is required to put pressure
like we tried to do this the nice way
you didn't want to do it then we're
gonna do it the hard way
so I I discovered that Scott helm had an
S and leaf at the time and I thought oh
this is really opportune what we'll do
is we'll do a demo we'll do a video so I
went home to my home on the Gold Coast
so I'm sitting there in the Sun so I'm
nice and happy he's in England so he's
miserable and I said okay what we'll do
is we'll do this video where I control
your car and then we'll put that on the
Internet
so I want to show you a little piece of
the video see what I can control from
this end and I guess the the first thing
is I can see that you're you have to be
jet run it's cold there should we look
at what we might be able to do if the
heater see if we can bring you up to
Australia temps for a little bit okay so
straight after that I go and hit this
URL so there's to get request this
Scott's VIN number if any wants to take
a photo that he sold the card all right
so so now there's actually someone else
has been number we don't know who so we
hit this request and it comes back with
the JSON response like this and and one
of the things to note here is that it it
does have identifiable data in it so
when I see user ID like Scott home one
it's like yeah that's probably got hell
yeah and then if you were to enumerate
through VIN numbers of course you could
start to pull other identities and then
if you had a resource such as a database
full of loads of breached records you
can actually figure out the full
identity the person so here's what
happened after we hit the URL
it's beeping oh there we go oh my heated
seats have come on conditioning and the
funds have just come on as well you can
see there's a status indicator on the
dash but the cars currently been
controlled remotely which is now
blinking and I'm not sure if you can
hear that but all of these funds have
come home full powers actually quite
while we've been here and that was it it
was like literally I can sit at home on
the other side of the world and start
controlling features of his car so it's
worthwhile taking a moment just to think
about like how this happens what are the
mistakes that make things like this
happen so we'll take a scenario like
this this is Scott now Scott's using his
mobile app and the experience that he
has is whatever is built into the app
this is what he's looking at behind the
app of course it's hitting an API now
it's probably obvious anyway but it's
not like the car is running Apache right
like the api's host on this and services
they then communicate over GSM back
channel to send commands backwards and
forwards to the car so that's what
happens in that piece now people get
very focused on this relationship
between the user and the mobile device
so they're thinking about what's the
experience they have what can they do
what if they misuse the mobile app but
they neglect this piece and this is what
I was talking about just before when you
use a mobile app you're not seeing how
it's communicating with the api's behind
you've literally got to reverse engineer
at proxy through and have a look at
those api's so we've got to pay a lot
more attention to what's happening in
this part of the picture this was a big
problem for Neeson it took their service
offline for some length something like
about six weeks
obviously it required a lot more
engineering effort they had to
completely redo their author mechanism
because Vin's obviously aren't secrets
and they eventually got it back online
and the app looked like this and Scott
sent me a message he said here's the app
notice anything weird about the app and
he says have a look have a look here do
you see anything unusual about this app
that Nissen has made and shipped to car
owners
and I'm looking at the bottom at the app
explanation okay yes actually that is
unusual I wonder why you would put that
in a car app why do you reckon they put
that in the car app let's go and find
out let's go to stack overflow someone
knows how to copy and paste so he hid
literally copied and pasted data out of
Stack Overflow and put it in an
application that controls a car and you
know what's even worse have a look at
the second word here have a look at the
second word there
they didn't even cop him face it someone
retype the whole thing and put it in
software that controls a car for anyone
interested there is really good job
security in this industry just putting
it out there so the app obviously was
offline for quite a while and some
people got quite upset about that as
well and this guy left a Google Play
review and he really didn't like the
fact the app was offline and he actually
got a bit upset with me and I I always
features a very polite English way of
insulting someone who's like rather
stupid but to me it was like a reminder
you know there are people out there that
genuinely need help from themselves that
don't realize the risks that are
presented and I thought well I should
keep this reminder so I printed out and
framed him front of my desk and that's
just a little reminder that these things
happen and people do need some saving
from themselves all right so another
another attack that we keep seeing that
is continually effective is cross-site
scripting and I've got a short video
here from a Dutch journalist called
Brenner de vente and I saw him present
this in Amsterdam a few years ago and he
wanted to demonstrate that even Dutch
banks have a lot of cross-site scripting
vulnerabilities so he did this short
demo and everything you see in here is
done via XSS its XSS that is loading in
CSS and loading in an mp3
and they're real banks here's what he
did
[Music]
endless fun you can actually see in the
URL up towards Ian there's a bit of evil
in there so people regularly use eval to
try and circumvent like firewall
detection and things like this so XSS
keeps happening now there are a couple
of other things we can do with XSS that
are native to the browser that a lot of
people don't know about and I thought
would give you a bit of a demo of so I'm
going to jump over to a little website I
created called search for beer common
and this one is actually live so you can
go to search for beer calm yourselves
it's great all you do is you type in
beer and you search for it and it comes
back and says you search for beer any
questions about this site alright so
that's all it does now what I have done
on this site is if I have a look at the
response headers of this homepage and I
go there in my response headers I've set
X XSS protection to zero now what we can
talk about here is the browser's native
XSS auditor so this is built into Chrome
and it helps protect against cross-site
scripting every now and then someone
turns it off so what we're gonna see now
is not the default position of Chrome
it's what happens when you turn it off
very often people turn it off because
they're trying to do really really
screwy things they get an error they go
to stack overflow that copy and paste
the answer and here we are turned off so
when it's turned off we can do stuff
like this we can say hey because I like
beer so much let's actually do an alert
box for beer like that and then we'll
close off that script tag like that and
I'll put on the clipboard because we're
gonna use this a few times and you get
BAM awesome
you pop an alert because what it's doing
is it's just reflecting the input into
the source code and now you got a script
tag in your source code pretty
straightforward now let's go on to the
next tab because what I've got here is
XSS protection actually turned on to one
so once we put it on one it's going to
look like this now what happens when
it's on one let's do the same search BAM
now let box and if I go and look at the
source code of the page will see that
the alert has actually popped up in red
and chrome is saying token contains
reflected XSS vector so what Chrome's
looking for is it's looking for a piece
of script in the URL which then appears
in the body and if it sees it it blocks
it it won't run it and this happens
natively you don't have to do anything
in your web app like you sure you still
shouldn't have XSS vulnerabilities you
should output in code all of your
untrusted data all this sort of stuff
but if you do this saves you now that's
cool that'll appear there and also if I
go back to here and I look at the
console of this page we'll get the same
error message there now that's still not
the default in Chrome now if I go to the
next one just here let's look at our
network tab we'll reload the page like
this I've now set XSS protection to 1
mode block now this is Chrome's default
so this is what will happen if you
haven't turned it off and what happens
this time is this Chrome literally kills
the entire page it says error blocked by
XSS auditor and the reason that does
this is that if it doesn't kill the
entire page and a duck just does what
exercise protection one does someone can
always pass a piece of script in the URL
which is also contained legitimately in
the source code and effectively disable
that script and you don't want that
because you don't want some arbitrary
third person being able to disable bits
and pieces of JavaScript on your page so
this literally kills the whole page so
this is what will happen by default and
that's good but there's something we can
do beyond that which is extra cool and
it's this network tab will reload this
page go up to the first request
we can declare a report and then provide
a URI and what this does is it's a
little bit like the content security
policy report we saw before so you can
say if the browser's XSS auditor fires
send me a report so I know about it
because you do want to know about this
stuff like if someone is actually
triggering off the XSS order to on your
web site you want to know about it
because it's probably something you're
gonna have to fix so to see this one in
action I'm going to open up fiddler
because we won't be able to see the
network requests in chrome it's gonna
kill the page before that shows and I'm
gonna say hey run search that's going to
go through fiddler it fails I can then
go over to here into my inspectors into
the raw request and we can see that that
posted off to demo it report URI it's
posted a JSON payload so I can go to the
JSON tab have a look at it there and
this is what would be sent to you so
you've got everything that you need
there in order to actually figure out
what happened in case it's a bit small
for those of you in the back that is
just the entire request URL that
contains the reflected XSS so you can
take that information you can go to your
website and you can say oh I've got a
problem here because I've got untrusted
data in the URL it's being reflected in
here it's firing the XSS auditor not
only is it a potential vulnerability but
it's actually killing the page for
anyone using Chrome now like CSP that's
totally free as well that's built into
the browser and all you got to do is to
specify report URI and send your reports
you can report to us at report eurocom
you can build your own reporting in
point and point there so again that's
kind of one of these things which is
here but it's got really really low
adoption because most people don't know
it exists okay something something a
little more I Oh T like continuing on
from the car theme kids tracking
Watchers anyone got their kid a tracking
watch oh okay you guys gonna love this
where do we start here I'm trying to
think of a polite way to put it now
several people from the hand up there
are parents that are very worried about
their children being kidnapped or going
missing or something like this so they
buy GPS tracking watches so these are
watches that have a 3G SIM card they can
communicate over the web and they can do
things like send the location of the
child they got a GPS built into them
they can hit an API they can say hey you
know a little Johnny little Mary this is
where they are they're wandering around
they're safe you know they're at school
they've got features to do things like
the child can call the parent if they're
in distress or something like that the
parent can call the child now for me
every time I see like a cheap Internet
an Internet connected thing I'm like
well this probably isn't going to be
very good and this is what's happened
here so I had a friend of mine in the UK
a penetration tester called Ken Munroe
he's a very notable guy over there he
does a lot of TV's a very very well
renowned security tester and he got in
touch they said look we have been
testing children's tracking watches and
they're generally terrible security wise
and in fact in 2017 they did a bunch of
testing and also did some work with one
of the Norwegian consumer protection
councils and they found really serious
problems and your council here ended up
putting out guidance saying you really
shouldn't use these that went to the
u.s. the u.s. went look these things
just got too many risks Germany banned
them completely in fact they said look
if anyone has these you should destroy
them now but I MUC around the Germans so
anyway Ken says look this particular
company is Australian Australian owned
and operated you're an Australian can
you go and buy one of these watches and
we'll test it we'll see if there's any
problems so this is tick-tock track I
went to the tick-tock track website and
when I go to a website I'm always trying
to get a little bit of a sense of you
know is this going to be a problematic
thing security wise or not and then I
saw the padlock so I knew it would be ok
it's not how it works also every time I
see a statement like we take the
security of your data seriously it's
usually in a data breach disclosure
statement which is then followed by by
the way we lost your data
it never kind of bodes well so I'm
looking at this website going are these
these are probably going to be terrible
I really don't think we can trust these
so I bought one and put on my daughter
and this is Elle she's six years old and
we thought you know we'll use this thing
in the way it's meant to be used so we
can demonstrate the problem so I buy one
of these tick-tock track watches and one
of the first things I notice is the
tick-tock track watch is called Gator
and Gator is a Chinese company and they
make these children's watches and then
they sell them around the world and
other people build services on top of
them there's nothing wrong with the
Chinese made watch per se I've got one
on my wrist it has a little Apple logo
on it the thing is that these are made
exceptionally cheaply and when you pick
it up and you look at it you're like wow
that's it is an exceptionally cheap
watch and the challenge then is you've
got this one manufacturer making the
watch shipping it around the world and
then you've got all these different
companies around the world building
their own software on top of it so
building their own API layer and then
building their own web interfaces so the
security of those two things is really
at the mercy of lots of different
small-time companies building the
software now this is the tick-tock track
which is a gator what we wanted to do is
have a look at how it communicates
backwards and forwards so one of the
things that Ken did is he had a look at
how you retrieve family information now
there's this whole concept of a family
like the family owns the child the
family has control over the child their
location on this sort of thing and we
noticed a get request here to an API
that passes an identifier now because
Ken can count ken can hack so he changed
the number and you'll never guess what
happened this is an insecure direct
object reference or Idol and it's like
just the most basic well-known security
risk in the world change the number get
another record and this was literally it
it wasn't like there was no security you
had to be authenticated it just didn't
matter who you were authenticated as so
we ended up creating two accounts like I
had an account for my watch Ken here
another account for his watch he'd log
on to his account and then he'd pull
back data about mine so we did this in a
way where it didn't compromise anyone
else's personal data now a tangential
note on this you'll see in a moment all
ends up in the media when it was in the
press reporters are talking to the
company and they're saying look we'd
like to know how many Aussies are
impacted by this can you tell us how
many people bought tick-tock track
watches and the companies like look this
is commercially sensitive data we really
don't want to share how many we've sold
and I'm looking at it girl I reckon I
know how many of sold it's like if you
don't want people to know this don't put
it in the freaking API requests so
anyway this one gets a family this API
then returns this response so when you
say get family with that integer it
comes back with personally identifiable
data such as this now again keep in mind
you can increment the number and you can
enumerate through however many people
actually own a tick-tock track watch we
don't know and pull back all this
information there is then another API
that allows you to retrieve a child with
a freaking post request thank you very
much by going to this URI and again you
pass a family ID family ID has no
authorization actually on that family
you can relocate a child so you can
decide where you would like the child to
be which is alarming and what we end up
doing is we literally did this
demonstration where we took out we took
her away from the Tennis Club and Ken
dumped her in the ocean metaphorically
and I'm looking at the applet babies in
the water because this is what you could
do and then it got even worse so one of
the problems with the device is that
because everything just relied on you
specifying a number every API was
vulnerable one of the api's is an API
that lets you decide who the parent is
the reason that's significant is only a
parent can call the child because hey to
be weird if strangers were calling your
child
so we changed the parent from myself to
one of Ken's colleagues ago I could've
been jealous you're gonna hear what
happened next so then jealous uses his
vulnerability to make himself the parent
and then he calls Elle and I what's that
after was like holy [__] that is scary
like I'm I okay I was there and I knew
it was gonna happen but it was still
freaky and it was changing your number
and the fact that it was changing a
number means that no one ever tested her
because it's the first thing you'd ever
test so clearly it was built on a
shoestring it was shipped out very
quickly no one really gave a damn about
the security of it now I mentioned the
media side of things it got a lot of
press and this lady is it's the lady who
made it originally and this is her being
interviewed sort of three or four years
ago and she'd sort of talk about our
parents where I don't the kids
helicopter parents were sort of stuff
I've made this to look after our
children unfortunately that the way it
was handled after the incident was
absolutely atrocious and there's a whole
bunch of different stuff that was said
but the one that sort of popped out in
my mind and if you think back to the
adult fanfiction thing before as well
the misdirection and the defensive nough
swen a security vulnerabilities pointed
out one of the things that was said
about Ken and I is they said we asked
that the media treat the situation for
what it is a group of hackers who have
found an issue in our security and took
the findings to the media and an actor
self-promotion now the chronology of it
was private disclosures service goes
offline the thing is safe then there's
public disclosure this is the way the
security industry works yet
organizations at the receiving end of
this that don't understand that yet is
still shipping devices to our kids
connected to the Internet
view it like this
so one of the really big problems we've
got in this industry is the inability of
the organization's building software and
hardware products to deal with
vulnerability disclosure and I want to
leave you with one final example that
which I think is just the perfect
epitome of what I'm talking about
there's a biometric padlock now there's
a YouTube account called the lock
picking lawyer and this is actually a
really cool YouTube account so this guy
goes and does physical penetration tests
on padlocks and everything from like
using bolt cutters to see how much force
it takes to break it through to picks
and things like this so anyway he finds
this padlock and the value proposition
is you don't need a pin you don't need a
key
you just need something that you always
have on you which is your fingers
unfortunately the padlock does have a
screw on the side so the lock picking
lawyer gets a screwdriver and the screw
does exactly what you think it does like
he undoes the screw and the lock comes
apart now that's not the good bit he
discloses this ethically privately to
the organization involved and he says
look I got your padlock I got my
screwdriver out undid the screw it came
apart and the company demonstrating
exactly what the problem is in the
industry at the moment comes back and
says this padlock is invincible to
people who do not have a screwdriver
and that is the problem we have in the
industry today thank you very much so
we've got about five minutes does anyone
have any questions I'd like to ask
everyone's just marveling at the padlock
right now also it's like really dark so
put your hand right up yeah so that the
scripting vulnerability like the XSS
what if the attacker in lines the script
so like just clarify what you mean by
inline it
okay so if you put it directly in a
script block also like the mage cart one
okay so one of the nice things about so
that let me paraphrase the question in
the mage cart demo I put in a script tag
and I said source and then I pulled it
from an external location and you're
saying aha
what if the attacker actually creates a
script block and they put that same
script in the script block when you have
a Content security policy by default you
can't have what's called unsafe inline
script and an unsafe inline script is
either script block or an HTML element
with JavaScript events on it unchanged
on blur at such at cetera so you can't
have that if you still want to have your
own script blocks you can either create
a hash of the script block and add that
as a script source or you can create a
nonce
and you can add that to the header and
also add it to an on-set repeat of the
script block so without sort of going
into detail now if you're google a
particularly google scott helm and CSP
script block you'll find that but yeah
CSP would also block that from happening
which is pretty cool yep
what are the rules and laws for
disclosing vulnerabilities we've found
good question any other questions
ah one of the difficult things as soon
as we get to laws and rules as we run
less like global internet and we're
asking questions which ultimately boil
down to different answers in different
jurisdictions I think probably the
easiest way to answer it is it there's
pretty acceptable practices for
disclosure and and for timelines if you
have a look at something like Google
project zero there they're there to find
vulnerabilities and disclose them
publicly and they work to a pretty
aggressive timeline as well and it
always involves obviously private
disclosure first and then providing an
allowable amount of time which can
differ depending on the impact of the
incident and also the effort involved to
fix it one of the things we can
emphatically say is that no one ever
agrees so there's never like complete
consensus for something like tick-tock
track we literally said look you've got
three days and the reason you got three
days is this allows bad people to track
your children and it's really easy just
to turn off the service like planes
aren't going to crash because we turn it
off it's just like people aren't gonna
be able to track their children for a
few days if it's things that are like
critical windows components and they
need to be patched but the likelihood of
exploitation is lower it might be a
month but yeah this is there's not
general consensus on it as well it's
never one it's never illegal to disclose
oh yeah I I think it's very dependent on
circumstances and we see really big
debates about this there was one a few
years ago where a senior executive from
Oracle wrote publicly about look it's
never okay to test our software you just
can't and she got absolutely thrown
under the bus for it yeah literally
crucified I think she lost her job out
of it as well but yeah it's yeah if you
take that line of thought people will
find all sorts of problems and you won't
know who they are
any other questions yeah so you talked
about supply chain and managing
JavaScript's and stuff say someone
managed to compromise the CDN and
injected the mage car to some GS is
there any protection for that so
question there in case oh no couldn't
hear what happens if you like
compromised a CD and like you compromise
the
javascript that you're already loading
from some in you trust so we have sub
resource integrity for that also known
as sr iso sr i allows you to take an
external dependency either a javascript
file or a CSS file create a hash of it
put that as an integrity attribute on
either your style tag or your script tag
and then if that file ever changes then
the browser will reject it and it won't
run it and if any wants to see how that
works look at the source code of have I
been pwned every external script that I
embed has got an integrity attribute on
it so folks we're at time I've still got
a pile of stickers here please come and
grab them stick them on all your things
and thank you very much for coming
[Applause]